parents are really concerned there isn't
enough school security after reports of
fights on school buses and campuses this
year kate houston spoke to a family in
the southwest who had to withdraw their
child from classes after an incident
last week the person that punched her
she brought her friends her family her
mother
to the school and they physically
attacked my daughter autumn samuel says
her daughter was attacked while waiting
to get on her school bus at desert oasis
high school on december 16. it's
traumatic it's frustrating it's angering
and i don't see a resolution samuel
reports there was one police officer
using pepper spray to control the crowd
paramedics were also called i have not
slept i can't i mean i'm i'm so angry
that this happened to my daughter
when i sent her some place that was
supposed to be safe ccsd assigns two
police officers to each high school as
well as campus monitors but samuel says
more needs to be done to vet the people
coming onto school grounds it's going to
happen again to somebody else
my daughter is not the only one that's
happened too it's going to happen to
other people because there's there's
nothing else they just say we don't have
enough staff we don't have enough people
there should be somebody else out there
more people out there ccsd police have
opened an investigation meanwhile samuel
says the people responsible are still
harassing her family i don't see any
action and i mean i promise i will not
stop till i get justice for her though
this should have never happened kate
houston live local now